so I'm Julie I design and build stuff at
github I it's kind of difficult to
describe what I do to people who ask in
passing just because I'm somewhere in
between a designer and a front-end
engineer or developer you can find me
all over the internets well that sounds
really disgusting actually you can find
me on you know very appropriate social
media sites at nerdcore and that's three
hours I'm sorry what ok yeah yeah ok 44
in total we I stand corrected um ok so
um I know that the talk description
itself was a little mysterious so I kind
of want to go into more a little more
detail about what the talk is that I
will be giving today actually while I do
it so the description I gave was we
build systems we build systems that
evolve and grow with a company its users
and both of their needs and the way we
design and build these systems should
reflect the living breathing things we
want to create and leave more room for
them to grow so the question is like how
do we accomplish this with static assets
like Photoshop comms for example and the
answer is we don't the answer is we set
them all on fire and we start in the
future and for me and I think for a lot
of developers and designers who you know
code I think the future is very much the
browser okay so I did some very
scientific research because I wanted to
know what the you know general opinion
on Photoshop was and so I you know
obviously credible sources they grew
degree so the Internet agrees um because
[__] Photoshop other there may be a few
f-bombs dropped in this talk if you if
you didn't see that coming i apologize
thank you thank you for my inappropriate
pneus um ok so so the process so when we
use a one tool like Photoshop to design
and build websites we give that to land
the company who makes it absolute power
over our process we no longer can
control that process and it's a very
centralized right
um whoa okay so uh when I say that I
design in browser it doesn't mean that I
write code in web inspector and then
export it to you know some text editor
it means that i start in code and i
almost work exclusively in code so a
website design should start where it's
going to live and this is a quote by
Megan Fisher she's a really early
proponent of doing mock up and markup
and it's she's someone that I've
definitely followed and looked up to in
this respect so she definitely she and I
both believe that you should wherever
whatever you're building it should
probably start where it's going to live
or exist so for me I love building
things for the browser I i love WebKit i
love i love you know styling things
designing things been building them
specifically in browser we hear so we
hear the word dev environment all the
time but we never hear design
environment design tool is much more
common like you use a tool to design you
use photoshop you use illustrator use
fireworks sometimes maybe keynote I
heard that's like up and coming or
something so so it turns out the browser
actually provides a pretty neat little
package environment for designers and
I'm going to try to elaborate on that
what that means for you guys adds both
developers and if you're a designer as
well so so luckily I have some help it's
not just the browser doing all the work
I work primarily from the command line
is how I push and pull code to github
and that's where I host my coat
obviously I think I would not be working
there if I used bitbucket or some
equivalent of that so basically my
workflow is somewhat between you know a
text editor obviously my terminal and
then the browser so when I make design
decisions or design decisions I'm
thinking in code so css3 is [__]
beautiful so so it wasn't until css3
that we really had the option to create
really like you know the glossy sort of
really beautiful aesthetics that you can
you see in a lot of Photoshop comps with
sort of like the lighting effects
photoshop effects don't actually
translate pixel for pixel
um you know into the browser like colors
render differently in different browsers
and then shadows rendered differently
according to like what rendering engine
you know browser uses so so because css3
was our first shot at creating like
these effects in browser we got things
like multiple scalable background images
like you can see him this is something
from Dance Theatre home I don't know if
if anyone's familiar with him but he's
um he invented he started the company
dribble and has been a really successful
designer even before that and he wrote
the book apart about css3 so so along
with background images ingredients
lighting effects with box shadows and
transition with like interactive
elements like I don't know like a trenta
CSS rotating all these different things
now there's full animation libraries
that you can use to create the same
effects that we would normally use
JavaScript to create so there's always
going to be this inconsistency going
from comps to the browser so so the key
the key thing with that is not to panic
and to do the work now instead of later
so when you start in Photoshop and you
create this beautiful comp and you think
it's perfect and you ship it off to your
front-end developer and you say or maybe
you're on the other side of that and
you're the front-end developer who gets
that Photoshop comp handed to you so
implementing that design on the front is
you're gonna you're going to find a
couple things are different right you're
going to find that may be your type
doesn't render the same way you're going
to find that you know the color palette
looks slightly different in other
browsers and instead of going you know
back to photoshop it's a lot easier just
to start in the browser to begin with so
that you this is incredibly small for
for these screens but you can actually
see the text rendering differences Megan
Fisher again wrote an article about
designing in browser and pointed out the
font rendering effects and photoshop
don't really keep up with the browser
and i'm pretty sure with cs6 it just got
a little worse now you have these kind
of like arbitrary options of sharp chris
strong and smooth which obviously don't
translate to browser at all if you know
anything about text rendering and
browser it's either anti a list or
sub-pixel anti-alias
so it's becoming even more complicated
over necessary like not necessarily
commented okay so assassin s CSS are
your new best friend both as a designer
and a developer so if you're not
familiar with sass it's basically a tool
that kind of hack CSS to allow you to
pass in logic that spits out a value
that the browser can interpret so it
also allows you to do things like much
more efficiently so for example this is
like a really a momentary example but
for instance you can pass in a variable
here for the color gray and I can say
okay on the board on the top border of
this button I want to make that color
ten percent lighter and it actually
spits out that hex value in the browser
which then I mean if you decide you
don't want to have all of these
variables you can actually go back and
fill in the hex color that the browser
sits out but it's much better than
sitting and like a GUI and hand picking
the colors you know from your favorite
websites or whatever it is that you do
to get that consistency so you know the
opposite would be darkened you can take
that same variable and say I want to
darken this by ten percent and get those
effects without having to kind of repeat
the process in Photoshop another thing i
really really love about SAS and spss is
the way that it handles errors
specifically when you're writing like
for instance of rails app like we do at
github our main github com is a ruby on
rails app so what's great is it actually
throws syntax errors for you and tells
you what line of code is creating that
error which is really useful because if
you have ever written a CSS file before
it normally doesn't and you could have
left off like an arbitrary semicolon
from you know some element and you will
have to go through line by line to try
to find where where you [__] that up and
so it's a lot easier if the browser is
telling you you [__] up here go and
fix your mistake and everything will be
fine so the great thing another really
wonderful thing about designing in
browsers is that there's fewer surprises
like I said the translation from a
Photoshop comp into a you know a browser
is never going to be exactly precise but
and you don't really want to deal with
those surprises because if you're
working between
people it means that you can no longer
you can't do the job that you want to do
until they correct that mistake or make
it more consistent and that was in their
cons so you can create sort of this test
suite for yourself and have cross
browsers in as i like to call it and do
it all at the same time and this is sort
of the way that my design environment or
my dev environment is set up is i'll
have you know firefox i'll have safari
i'll have chrome obviously all running
at the same time and now with some
amazing developer tools you can actually
change like you can change the browser
agent to anything mobile you can do it
for like an older version of even IE now
on both browsers so it's really really
excellent to be able to kind of you can
see into the future a little bit instead
of [__] yourself in the beginning
okay so you can obviously with developer
tools another really great thing that's
in the browser is you can debug CSS
which like I said it could be a little
difficult when you don't have something
that's throwing you errors if you've
ever searched the web inspector for
something that's you know overriding a
style before you you can kind of you
understand that frustration and then you
can obviously get a bug JavaScript so
I'm not a JavaScript developer I write
JavaScript but it's not necessarily my
role at github and I know a lot of
people are going to cringe when I say
this but we actually now with anything
new that's written we write purely
coffee script and if you guys want to
see that you guys can go check out
github.com / style guide our style guide
is actually public and you can look at
it we use KSS which is a CSS
documentation that automatically
generates our style guide for us so it's
pretty up to date with the site so why
does why does the designer need to know
javascript or at least uh understand it
to understand that main concepts of
javascript is the interaction layer
right a designer you know you can see
the set places the big organizations
where it's just very granular like you
have a UX designer and then you have a
visual designer and then you have you
know a front-end coder and it's even
more granular than that at some places
but in order to totally understand the
experience you're creating
it's a designer you need to be able to
understand all of the interactions that
a user is experiencing when they go to
your site or your app whatever product
you're building so this is a little
hostile i realized that after writing it
but software crashes suck their kind of
the worst and a great thing is you know
when you're constantly refreshing your
browser you're you're hitting the save
button literally every time you make a
CSS change to view that change and so
you're kind of safeguarding yourself
from those photoshop crashes that
literally like screw your day like I
don't know anyone who has had that
happen to them who hasn't almost had an
emotional breakdown uh so so yeah so
yeah so we have a problem with the would
sell for quashing so obviously when you
save a file and then you refresh it in
browser it's not going to affect your
code at all okay so version control
version control is an awesome design
tool and I don't think enough designers
actually use it the way that it's I kind
of naturally evolved to be used by
designers so I'm going to give you guys
a few tips and maybe if you're not
necessarily a designer you guys can
start helping you know the designers you
work with understand why version control
is important to your process and getting
the kind of development process closer
to the zine process is kind of I don't
know I think it all I think it'll be a
lot more beneficial for kind of everyone
working together I don't know that
sounds kind of like okay okay so that
was a couple companies now doing this
where they use version control the to
manage their design assets square does
it github we definitely do it and
there's a couple github tools that can
actually help you do this a lot better
so long with tracking changes what we
have is image diffing do any of you guys
use image diffing on github yeah one
person two people I see like random
hands going up awesome I know you guys
are tired this is the last NOC it's so
image shipping is [__] awesome so I'm
going to take Facebook's logo and i'm
going to show you what you can do with
image dipping in a commit message
basically so you look at the commit and
you see that you know you've changed
this you want to see the exact
difference between the image
is that you swapped in and out of that
last commit so there's actually four
different modes of image differing and
github and the first ones to up and you
can see them side-by-side the second one
is swipe and you can actually kind of
you kind of you can drag the GUI like
you can drag it drag the anchors to the
side and it actually reveals like the
image beneath it the other one is onion
skin which is basically it's like an
opacity over the other image to see
maybe more like not so much in logos i
think but like in bigger kind of photos
to see like maybe change like the
rounded corners on something for
instance that's a good example okay they
via the oh my god I really thought that
part is when you accidentally delete an
image and you realize that the one you
just uploaded is worse or you made a
mistake so one amazing thing that you
can do with github is you can actually
go back and to that commit and you can
actually you know right click and save
your older image and replace it in your
next commit which is amazing because if
you've ever lost something you know
after you know and realize that it was
actually the thing you needed usually
there's not an out for that definitely
not in Photoshop so designers ask your
Deb's for commit access awesome because
it's the only way you're going to have
more control over the design process and
you're going to be I don't want to say
like more respected but you're
definitely going to have a bigger
opportunity to contribute to your team
and the product you're designing and
developers give your designers commit
access build more trust like your does
like they're gonna break some things
like your designers are going to break
some things but they might not and I
think once they do break some things
they're going to realize how to how to
get themselves out of that Jam or
realize what who they need to go to to
get themselves out of that Jam and it's
kind of invaluable when you're working
on a team and you're working you know
asynchronously so yeah command-line
tools are hard we get that I work from
the command line but most of our
designers actually use one of our
products to do that are like a GUI for
github essentially yeah we know gets
confusing but I think we have this down
so we have a product called github for
Mac
which is basically a GUI interface on
top of get that you can push to github
from and it's actually incredibly easy
to use you literally only hit sync and
it syncs the branches for you so there's
no push in pool unless you have and like
really bad conflict or merge conflicts
which doesn't usually happen if you're
just replacing assets so it's a pretty
safe thing to give your designers access
to so prototyping is great for the soul
so when it's really easy when you write
code so one thing that i do and i found
is a great prototyping tool is just
using the hell out of juice is one of my
favorite things to do so essentially you
can start with the code on a gist and
you know it doesn't obviously it
obviously doesn't have to be public but
there are some benefits to it being
public and one of those is adding
screenshots in the comments and maybe
even linking to a demo of that and also
receiving comments like people are going
to want to contribute to your project
and regardless of if even if it's just a
CSS snippet they may have a more
effective way of doing it and that's how
you learn and they learn so there's
another tool called ablett and it's an
open source tool made by leav arooo and
it's also really awesome because it
allows you to visualize just and it
actually saves that just to your github
when you write code and dalit so CSS is
usable so I we try to stay away from the
whole dry concept like don't repeat
yourself but don't write the same code
twice unless you can make it better or
unless you can improve it or someone
else can so if it's not reusable set it
all on fire and start over just burn it
to the ground so pattern libraries are
something that's been coming incredibly
interesting to me especially being a
friend encoder and a designer it's it's
a good way to like study how someone
else implements something and learn from
that but it's also a good way to reuse
the CSS and other other parts of the UI
that you normally implement it's really
great to kind of create those patterns
for the pattern libraries for yourself
but also for other for other people
okay so I learned how to code from
viewing source I didn't go to school for
computer science and I didn't really
have like a mentor I was really
interested in the way that the the web
worked it was the closest thing to magic
for me and so I really wanted to learn
how they how you know developers created
these certain effects I'm using pure CSS
so I learned from viewing source and I
think it's really important it's a
really important thing to you like past
that forward especially you know I think
designers tend to think of it as their
secret sauce but I mean realistically
their front end coder is just going to
take their take their photoshop comp
they're going to write CSS and you're
going to be able to view the source
regardless so it's better to make it
more consumable for other people in a
pattern library sort of like this so
pairs is something created by Dan
cederholm that he released I think and I
think April or May of this year and it's
really interesting because it's the
first thing that I've seen where it's
like a kind of consolidated front-end
library where you can you can view you
something visually but also keep track
of it based on like kind of a module or
like kind of object oriented CSS which
is really really [__] awesome so I
use gist and other pattern libraries to
open source things all the time because
i think that other people can make them
better i think one of the most common
things that happens is i'll open source
something in pure CSS someone will take
it and make like a compass mixed in or
you know apply some other yeah you know
preprocessor to it and I think that's
kind of really really [__] awesome
something that's not it's not really
like common when you think about
designers in general I think like the
first time I saw pattern libraries was I
used dribble buckets I don't know if any
of you four are familiar with us but I
basically use them to identify certain
visual patterns but I always wanted a
way to show the code for that like okay
how do you get there and so pairs is a
really great way to do that it's
actually written in PHP it's open source
but it's in it's on github but it's
written in PHP which I would you
couldn't pay me to touch so if any of
you want to write that in something else
I'll probably give you all my money so I
the future is what I'm hoping for is one
where designers are seen you know almost
as equally as developers are in building
products they sit at the table and
they're people who are respected by
their peers and also contribute as much
as developers due to the products
they're building so as of now I mean I
see this all the time on job sites when
I look at designer rules just to see
what the new qualifications are and how
they're changing all the time and one of
them is always pixel perfect Photoshop
comps like that's your responsibility
and if you're if you're told that's your
responsibility why would you learn
anything else like why would you step
outside of your normal realm in order to
challenge yourself if that's your only
responsibility so if that's your
responsibility then you're in product
that you're producing is a picture of a
website and we don't really build
pictures of websites we build websites
we build ass so I mean I think having
learning these things and designing and
browser is going to give you an
opportunity to have more control over
the process in general and contribute
more as well so you're all so [__]
awesome thanks for listening to me uh I
wanted to share a couple resources with
you guys so you can check out the github
style guide its price it's kind of
interesting to see the way we write code
we have like if they're more like
considerations and not hard rules so
that's not 24 ways and do your mock-up
and markup is the article written by
Megan Fisher which is an amazing article
about designing in browser it's a little
old but she was definitely one of the
pioneers of kind of making the shift
from static assets to a writing code
like starting in HTML and CSS and then
the dance theater home thing was the
links right here and then sass laying if
you don't if you haven't you sass before
it's definitely worth checking out and
if you haven't used just please use this
they're awesome I put up my buckets on
here because you can kind of see what i
mean about like visual patterns and
trying to kind of like consolidate them
just for not necessarily for like oh i'm
going to take this and i'm going to copy
but it's more about understanding like
how people interpret a certain like you
I piece or a certain like you know like
a drop down or something really really
simple like that it's just exposing
yourself to the different ways that
people do them and then pairs obviously
is a really cool thing to check out if
you if you write markup regularly but
anyways um that's it and if you have
questions I'd be glad to chat or and or
answer your questions now I think I'm
the last talk so we have about five
minutes I think whoo so awesome yeah so
if anyone has a question hey yeah oh do
you have any advice for people with a
very good photoshop skill how to transit
to do javascript and CSS skills yeah so
I I forget who said this earlier I
there's a lot of people who are really
interested with like the whole it
started in Dreamweaver right where you
can drop in a PSD and it'll right the
CSS for you and every every developer
cringes when they hear that you know so
I I don't recommend to like using one of
those tools because I think someone
mentioned before it was like using a GUI
is not really learning to code and
you're not going to learn how to solve
the problems that you're going to end up
facing or just kind of going to
overcomplicate things so let's learn to
code is my best piece of advice I mean
uh I mean I know what I just I don't
think software development is that hard
uh yeah I really don't I think it's I
think it's I think if there's a high
barrier to entry but I think if you're
passionate enough about what you do and
you want to contribute more and you want
to learn more the thing about designing
in browser is the browser's constantly
changing you know it's decentralized
obviously it's not in one tool but it's
constantly changing so it's constantly
forcing you to pick new things up right
and you uh you want to do that because
your coworkers are going to do that you
know and otherwise you're going to fall
behind and I don't know I mean it's not
the end of the world but I think that
it's it's it's going to always challenge
you so I guess my best
I should beat always to learn how to
code this is a question specifically
about comparing images and using github
for Mac and the the way that a lot of
design works is you produce multiple
versions of the same concept and they're
not it's not the same progression
forward the way it would be with other
code you would sort of branch out
literally and to say five ideas my
question is is it pretty simple for
someone who's a bit intimidated by get
to then compare their versions against
each other and the other I think problem
is when you when you want to see all of
them together is there any thought about
show me all the versions you know the
way that we do it is through purely
screenshots that's kind of the way we do
it the way we discuss different versions
is yeah you would you basically break
something out on a branch you know and I
don't think that part is necessarily
challenging but the workflow the way
that we do it and we find it really
efficient I don't know that it's the
easiest way is we essentially just after
we're done marking something up even if
you end up doing it in photoshop and you
just want to start a branch to start a
discussion you know and start a pull
request and start talking about you know
the different versions of the design we
literally just take screenshots and drop
them in and then we start pointing
things out I mean it's it's it's a good
it's a good visual way to discuss what's
going on in the code and if there's not
code it's a good way to discuss future
steps yeah one more question sir anyway
um so you talked about doing doing
design starting design entirely in code
right do you have any steps before thats
a paper or yeah anything else like um so
I saw this really amazing treat actually
I think it was from Jeff Broderick um
who said that designers actually spend
more time thinking than they do
designing and I think that's absolutely
right i think i think that uh if you're
not spending more time thinking then
designing you're just pushing pixels
push pixels and it's not really that
feeling of accomplishment that you're
probably looking for but yeah so I start
with sketching I sketch I I don't like
that's my the way that I used wireframes
basically is I sketch things out i
scribble my sketches look like a
third-grader did them they're pretty
awful but it definitely gives me an idea
of where to go like I'd usually don't
start from nothing right yeah cool thank
you guys all right Thank You Julie